Speaker 1: For me, joking about suicide is not
something that I do on the show. And I am not
someone who says, here's a list list of topics
you can never joke about. But on this program,
we do sometimes joke about things, but I don't
joke about suicide and it makes it all the more.
Interesting that the Ukrainian ambassador to
the United Nations, Sergey Kiss Lesia, yesterday
said in a serious way again without joking about
suicide, if Putin wants to end up dead, he should
just shoot himself dead the way Hitler did in the
bunker in 1945. And the point here is actually,
it's not a joke. It's if, for whatever reason,
Putin has a death wish. The desire to destroy
reckless, reckless desires which could lead to
him ending up dead. Don't kill other people. Just
kill yourself. And that's me paraphrasing
Let's listen to Sergei. Because Lithuania
yesterday to the United Nations,
Speaker 3: we have been prompted
to call for an emergency special session
as the level of the threat to the global
security has been equated today to that
of the Second World War. Or even higher
following Putin's order to put an alert,
Russian nuclear forces, what what a madness.
If he wants to kill himself,
he doesn't need to use nuclear
arsenal, he has to do what these see what
what the guy in Berlin did in a bunker
in May. Nineteen forty five,
Speaker 1: so of course, he's
referring to Hitler taking his own life, and I
think there is a point here that is a good one. If
Vladimir Putin has a death wish. Who wants to blow
everything up proverbially as much as literally
and end up dead, potentially? He could just take
himself out and not as many other people. I don't
think this is a joke about suicide. It's not a
question of encouraging suicide or any of it.
The sentiment that comes through here is
if you're determined to ruin your own life,
why do you have to ruin so many others as well? I
was watching video on Argentinean television this
morning. They have correspondents on the border
between Ukraine and Poland and to see the looks of
shock on people's faces as they flee Ukraine, some
literally unable to speak for periods of time.
From the shock that they are experiencing, you
don't have to ruin other people's lives if you're
simply determined to ruin your own now to some
degree. I would bet anything I have that the
topic of assassinating Putin has come up at the
top levels of government. I'm not saying anyone's
thinking of doing it. I'm not saying anyone plans
to do it or would do it, but without a doubt.
When AIDS are supposed to present all options to
world leaders, it is impossible to imagine that
they are coming forward and saying, OK, we can
send weapons. We could send troops. We could look
at drones. We can do this. We can do that. Here's
what it would look like if we tried to assassinate
Putin. It's clearly being mentioned by the people
who are paid to present all options to world
leaders. I don't believe it's being seriously
considered. I don't believe it's going to be done
and I'm not suggesting it be done. But the point
here from the Ukrainian ambassador once again is
not everybody has to suffer because Putin has
become a reckless tyrant, and that certainly is
coming through in the desperation of the voice of
the ambassador from Ukraine to the United Nations.